قسمه المصارف الامريكيه تعيد الى الاذهان
مشهدا مضى عليه اكثر من 90 عاما ولا يتمنى
العالم تكراره انه الكساد العظيم اكبر
كارثه اقتصاديه في القرن العشرين فما الذي
حدث وقتها ولماذا تنذر ازمه المصارف في
الولايات المتحده بكارثه مشابهه
[موسيقى]
هنا الولايات المتحده لم تخرجي البلاد بعد
من فوضى عواقب الحرب العالميه الاولى الى
ان جاء تاريخ الرابع والعشرين من اكتوبر
عام
1929 هجره جماعيه شهدتها اسواق الاسهم
الامريكيه في يوم واحد باع المستثمرون نحو
12 مليون و900,000 سهم وعلى مدى الاربعه
ايام التاليه تراجعت اسعار الاسهم بنسبه
23% لتعلن انهيار البورصه الامريكيه بعد
الانهيار الكبير لاسواق الاسهم بدا الكساد
الكبير وكان من ابرز اسباب حدوثه تكثيف
امريكا لانتاجها من البضائع المختلفه
لتغطيه الاسواق العالميه خلال الحرب
العالميه الاولى لكن بعد انتهاء الحرب
عادت عجله الانتاج الى الدول الاخرى
فاستغنت عن البضائع الامريكيه لتبدا
الكارثه اطنان من البضائع تكد معامل
وشركات اغلقت ابوابها ونحو 13 مليون
امريكيا خسروا وظائفهما لتصل نسبه البطاله
الى نحو
25% وتنخفض معدلات الاجور بنسبه
42% بدايه الكساد الكبير جاءت في الرابع
والعشرين من اكتوبر عام
1929 في ذلك اليوم انهارت البورصه
الامريكيه وتراجعت قيمه الاسهم باكثر من
ثلاثه وعشرين بالمئه مع موجه كبيره نحو
البيع وكان هذا اليوم البدايه الفعليه
للكساد الكبير
البنك المركزي الامريكي لم
يتح من البنوك لا سيتم الصغيره منها ولم
يقتصر دوره السلبي على ذلك فقط بل اساء
ايضا اداره السياسه النقديه قبل وبعد
الازمه ففي عام 29 مثلا زادت الودائع
المصرفيه باكثر من النصف وارتفعت المدخرات
بنسبه
224% ونمى المعروض النقدي بنحو
61% لكن رغم تلك الارقام الايجابيه ابقى
المركزي الامريكي معدلات الفائده منخفضه
وهو ما تسبب في حدوث فقاعات في القطاعات
الاقتصاديه المختلفه كل ذلك ادى الى تراجع
الناتج المحلي الامريكي من 103 مليارات
دولار الى 55 مليار دولار فقط وهنا بدات
رياح الكارثه تتجاوز الحدود الجغرافيه
للولايات المتحده
العالم كله انقلب راسا على عقب وعم الذعر
جميع دول العالم لدرجه ان حجم التجاره
العالميه انخفض بنسبه 65% ما ادى الى
انتشار الفقر في كثير من مناطق العالم
الخبراء صنف اثار هذا الكساد في المرتبه
الثانيه بعد الحرب العالميه ومنذ تلك
الفتره بدا العالم يتابع بحذر دوراتها
الاقتصاديه حتى يتمكن من التحوط ضد اي
افلاس او كساد قادم لكن السؤال الذي يطرح
اليوم هل تنذر الازمه المصرفيه الحاليه
بكساد قادم بدايه علينا ان نفرق بين
الركود والكساد الركود هو انكماش اقتصادي
على مدى اشهر متتاليه بينما الكساد هو
حاله من التدهور الاقتصادي الحرج الذي قد
يستمر لسنوات هو اشبه بالسقوط من القمه
الى الحضيب بالنسبه للاقتصاد
وبعض الخبراء يطمئنون العالم بان ما يحدث
الان لا ينذر بخطر تكرار الكساد الكبير
مره ثانيه
الاقتصاد الحالي لا يزال على ما يرام
المستهلكون ينفقون الاموال ولا يزال لديهم
الكثير من الاموال وميزانياتهم العموميه
في حاله جيده والتجاره في الابنيه
والعقارات في حاله جيده والوظائف وفيره
هذا جيد جدا هذا هو الواقع
قابل
خبراء اخرون ان العالم
في مرحله الركود ومن المحتمل لهذا الركود
ان يصل الى القاع قريبا خاصه بعد افلاس
بعض البنوك كبنك سيليكون فاني